you mentioned big dog can you can we
maybe take a stroll through the history
of Boston Dynamics uh so what and who's
Big Dog by the way is who
do you try not to anthropomorphize the
robots do you try not to try to remember
that they're this is like the division I
have because I for me it's impossible
for me there's a magic to the there's a
being that is a robot it is not human
but it is
the same Magic
uh the living being has when it moves
about the world is there in the robot so
um I don't know what question I'm asking
but uh should I say what or who I guess
who is Big Dog what is big dog
well I'll say to address the medic
question we don't try to draw hard lines
around it being an it or a him or a her
um it's okay right people I think part
of the magic of these kinds of machines
is by nature of their organic movement
of the of their Dynamics
we tend to want to identify with them we
tend to look at them and sort of
attribute
maybe feeling to that because we've only
seen things that move like this that
were alive
and so
um this is an opportunity it means that
you could have
a feelings for a machine and you know
people have feelings for their cars you
know they get attracted to them attached
to them so that's inherently could be a
good thing as long as we manage what
that interaction is
so we don't put strong boundaries around
this and ultimately think it's a benefit
but it's also can be a bit of a curse
because I think people look at these
machines
and they attribute a level of
intelligence that the machines don't
have why because again they've seen
things move like this that we're living
beings
which are intelligent
and so they want to attribute
intelligence to the robots that isn't
appropriate yet even though they move
like an intelligent being but you try to
acknowledge that the
anthropomorphization is there and try to
first of all acknowledge that it's there
and have a little fun with it you know
our most most recent video
it's just kind of fun you know to to
look at the robot we started off the the
video with Atlas
um kind of looking around for where the
bag of tools was because the guy up on
the scaffolding says send me some tools
and Atlas has to kind of look around and
see where they are and there's a little
personality there that is fun it's
entertaining it makes our jobs
interesting and I think in the long run
can enhance interaction between humans
and robots that in a way that isn't
available to machines that don't move
that way